c'est un grand symbole pour les affaires
[Musique]
vous dites que vous aimez vos enfants par-dessus tout
et pourtant vous volez leur
avenir
[Musique] [
Musique]
la première fois que j'en ai entendu parler, c'était
peut-être quand j'avais 8 ans et mes
professeurs  à l'école m'en a parlé et
ils nous ont montré des films et
des photos d'ours polaires affamés et de
plastique dans l'océan et j'en étais vraiment
affecté je suis devenu très triste
et j'ai pensé que c'était très étrange
je me demandais pourquoi cela pouvait être comment cela
pourrait être qu'il y avait une crise existentielle
qui menacerait notre civilisation et
notre existence et pourtant ce n'était pas une
première priorité, nous nous concentrions sur d'autres
choses et nous n'étions pas en train d'en
parler, je pense que le tournant
dans  ma vie où j'ai décidé que j'allais
faire quelque chose à propos de la
crise climatique était peut-être quand j'avais 11 ans
et puis je suis tombé malade je suis tombé dans une
dépression et je et mais ensuite je
me suis dit que je pouvais faire tellement de
bien avec mon  la vie à la place et c'est
juste une perte de temps de se sentir comme ça
et alors j'ai décidé de faire quelque chose
de ma vie devrait essayer de faire une
différence quand j'ai parlé pour la première fois à mes parents
de mon idée avec la grève scolaire ils
n'étaient pas très friands  de l'idée qu'ils ont dite,
n'y a-t-il rien d'autre que vous puissiez faire
pour essayer de changer les choses et de faire
entendre votre voix et j'ai dit non, je vais
le faire
car j'avais pris ma décision et je n'allais pas
laisser quelqu'un me dire de ne pas le faire
certaines personnes me demandent si je le suis si je suis plein d'
espoir ou pessimiste ou optimiste et je
dis que je suis réaliste je dis que c'est ce que
je dois faire et c'est
ce que j'ai  faire pour pouvoir
le faire et alors j'ai juste décidé de
le faire parce que je suis une fois j'ai décidé de
faire quelque chose je le fais et je le termine j'ai
dit que je me tiendrai ici devant
le parlement suédois tous les vendredis
jusqu'à ce que la Suède soit  conformément à l'
accord de Paris et lorsque tout le monde commence à
réaliser que nous sommes confrontés à une
crise existentielle, mon message aux
jeunes est que nous devons réaliser ce que
les générations plus âgées nous ont fait
et continuer à faire en ce moment même et
ne nous arrêterons pas jusqu'à quelque chose  se passe
et nous devons les tenir responsables de
ce gâchis qu'ils ont créé et nous devons
faire entendre une voix et nous mettre en colère
, puis transformer cette colère en
action
[Musique]
cher m.  McComb, vous devez agir
maintenant, pas seulement parler d'agir
parce que si vous continuez
comme d'habitude, vous allez échouer
et si vous échouez, vous allez être considéré
comme l'un des pires méchants de l'histoire de l'humanité.
Musique]